[Music]
some kids look like their parents but we
found 10 that looked like exact mini
versions of our favorite Disney
Princesses don't miss number one to see
the real-life child Merida from brave if
this is your first time visiting the
things don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
here's ten kids who look exactly like
Disney Princesses Elsa from birthday
cakes to school bags and Halloween
costumes looking like Elsa has
definitely been trending since the
release of Disney's frozen in 2013 some
actors even dress up like the ice queen
to help bring a smile to sick children
in hospitals or acting like the life of
the party at children's birthdays this
little kid is stealing the show when it
comes to look-alikes her soft wispy
blond hair and huge blue eyes make her
Elsa's twin she even has a mischievous
grin that mirrors Elsa's confidence in
spot finally those long eyelashes and
raised eyebrows really make her look
like a Disney Princess in the making Val
in an independent article it stated that
Belle from Beauty and the Beast is the
first Disney Princess to have hazel eyes
for this reason depending on where she
is and what she's wearing her eyes will
either appear as a light color green or
as a pale brown this beautiful child has
piercing green grey eye color that fits
the bill in scenes when Belle's eyes are
greener these two are exactly alike
they're both lips and shining eyes
framed by thick eyelashes are what makes
both these beauties look innocent and
clever all at once even the golden brown
hair in delicate waves makes this kid an
exact duplicate of valve rapunzel
rapunzel was heralded for bringing to
life Disney's 50th animated movie
tangled she's a spunky princess and the
movie features her self-discovery as she
escapes the confines of her tower where
she had been brainwashed for the benefit
of her evil witch captor Mother Gothel a
real-life child who looks just like
Rapunzel needs to convey a similar tough
attitude and this blonde cutie does
exactly that though her hair is
obviously shorter than the Disney
Princesses iconic looks
she has beautiful blond shiny hair
and the same defiant smile her eyes like
Rapunzel's shine green under arched
eyebrows that let us know she's not a
princess to mess with Tiana Disney's
princess and the frog star Tiana has a
vivacious attitude and optimism that are
as contagious as four-year-old Instagram
star twins Megan and Morgan these cuties
capture all of tiana sass and her
softness and then multiply it by two
their hair is even styled the same as
Tiana and their pouts remind us of
Tiana's resistance when she has to
pucker up and kiss the Frog when they're
smiling their dimples stand out just
like Tiana instead of Tiana's golden eye
color these two have amazing blue eyes
Morgan actually has an eye condition
called heterochromia where each eye is a
different color
Jasmine Princess Jasmine has been adored
and discussed since Disney released the
animated film in 1992 the setting of
Aladdin is fictional and represents
elements of both the Middle East and
India this upsets viewers who believe
that as two separate cultures they
shouldn't be conflated into one just for
the pleasure of an American audience
even Jasmine's features have been
contested as not middle-eastern this kid
might confirm that jasmine is not a
depiction of what Middle Eastern women
look like we still found a kid that
looks just like her but is of Dominica
Italian and african-american descent
this little girl's long dark hair bright
brown eyes and broad smile make her look
exactly like Jazmin Mulan Mulan is an
inspiring Disney story and Mulan
demonstrates extreme perseverance and
doesn't let anyone tell her something is
impossible her expressive face also
helps the audience connect with her
while she remains in disguise this
adorable 4 year old is exactly what we
imagined new on to look like as a real
child her hilarious expression with her
gaping mouth and rosy cheeks makes her
look young and spunky just like Milan
does when her grandmother is trying to
encourage her to act and look more like
a lady
this isn't the only photo of the
four-year-old that reminds us of Milan's
can-do attitude
Japanese photographer Kotori Kawashima
published a book of a series of photos
with this kid Esmerelda Disney gave a
voice to a
historically suppressed Roma population
through Esmeralda in the Hunchback of
Notre Dom she is a multi-faceted
character who's concerned with standing
up for what's right and defending her
people and community she is also very
seductive and serves to both challenge
and confuse the villainous judge Frollo
her green eyes stand out in contrast to
her thick dark brown hair the kid who
looks exactly like her even has the same
piercing green eyes and thick brown
curls she trades in Esmeralda's gold
dangle earrings for a colorful necklace
that reminds us of Esmerelda's colorful
clothes even the white flower replaces
as Morel dose scarf headband Ariel if
Ariel from The Little Mermaid had what
do you call them again
oh yeah feet we're pretty sure she would
have grown up looking exactly like this
little girl her bright red hair is swept
up in a ponytail to reveal her huge blue
eyes that look exactly like Ariel's when
she first surfaces from the water with
her own set of legs and feet even her
long eyelashes are accounted for you can
tell this little girl won't give up on
her dreams with a determined pout like
Ariel's surprisingly in the live-action
remake the iconic red hair will be
replaced by a blond Ariel Moana Disney
proved that they've still got it with
the release of Moana in 2016 that earned
them Academy Award nominations for Best
Animated Feature and Best Original Song
audiences fell in love with Moana for
her spunk and determination as she
follows through on the ocean selection
of her to embark on an adventure to save
her people Moana as a baby is just about
the cutest thing we've ever seen and
we're thrilled to announce that a photo
of a three month old is proof that baby
Moana exists in real life this beautiful
child has Mona's bright curious brown
eyes and her short curly hair she even
has the same adorable puffy cheeks
Merida our final kid will force you to
take a second look because she looks
exactly like Merida from brave from the
wild bright red head of girls to the
huge round blue eyes this kid is an
exact real-life version of the fear
Disney Princess her smile just like
Meredith's shows her enthusiasm to learn
how to be just like the grown-ups that
inspire her in fact
Merida holds a special place in many
fans hearts as a princess who breaks
free of the glitter idealized mold and
instead isn't afraid to be herself and
be brave not needing anyone to do a
rescuing on her behalf which is your
favorite kid look-alike let us know in
the comments and that's all for the ten
kids who look exactly like Disney
Princesses make sure to LIKE the video
and subscribe to the things to watch
more videos like this one thanks for
watching
[Music]